Oh
well you all know what I thought of the
first Princess Diaries and now we have
the sequel and I have to say it totally
took me by surprise I don't think I've
laughed so hard in such a long long time
oh not because the writing is any good
not because the acting is any good on
the contrary all those elements are
absolutely horrendously awful resulting
in an absolutely hilarious piece of shit
that's right it's one of those so bad
it's good movies you wouldn't think that
with Disney this would be the franchise
to war in such a distinction but man
it's not only bad it's nostalgia critic
bad I mean I'm seriously thinking about
putting this on the list someday
the story is Anne Hathaway is almost
hitting 21 which means she's gonna be
Queen soon but a bad guy played by John
rhys-davies wants to take the throne
from her how do I know because he
literally announces it you should be
more careful your royal highness
somebody might try to take that away
from you someone like me and on top of
that everyone I mean frigging everyone
announces it in the movie to like it was
made for four-year-olds please try to
keep up or dita he's trying to steal the
crown oh wait it gets better
so all the parliament decides that in
order for Anne Hathaway to become a
queen she has to marry how does she know
this because she finds a secret passage
that is so obviously labeled it's so
impossible for it to be called a secret
passage but it gets better so they
literally invite the villains to stay
with them in their palace why because
they want to keep their enemies close so
close that they could sabotage
everything which is exactly what they do
but wait it gets better
so the son of the guy who's trying to
take over falls in love with the
princess and they do that cliche where
they do nothing but bicker and yellow
each other yet you know they're gonna
get together yet they forgot to put in
any element of them actually liking each
other look at this scene they're yelling
and saying how much they hate one
another and then they just kiss where
the hell did that come from
I lost you I love you
we seen that cliche before but they
usually has to be something about them
that they have in common or they like
and here there's nothing they're just
forced right into it
the waste it gets better now that she's
got to become queen in literally 30 days
not only does she have to find someone
to marry but do you think now they're
finally gonna talk about the politics
and the importance of her kingdom and
touring it and stuff no they have more
important things like learning how to
wave their fans and having slumber
parties that's right the fate of their
whole nation could crumble in the matter
of days and yet they're going mattress
surfing oh the fate of your country
doesn't matter when you can be having
song sequences with Raven and it just
gets stupider and stupider and stupider
I am thoroughly convinced that this
movie even though it has a PG rating and
even though it's marketed to preteens
teens and even some adults would only be
enjoyed by kindergartners it is
literally written for kindergartners
Sophia the first has more dignity and
intelligence than this bill and I
enjoyed it from beginning to end it is
that horrendous ly bad it's good so yeah
in a strange way I kind of recommend it
if you're looking for one of those
movies that mocked every cliche and
every horrifying storytelling element
without it even realizing it's doing it
then this movie is for you I can
understand someone saying it's just a
cliche boring piece of crap that there
is nothing actually so bad it's good in
it but man it was full of it for me this
movie brought me so much joy god bless
you you horrible horrible film